all right welcome to Edna I'd like to
introduce our newest member
representative Juliet Smith who's
joining us
and
welcome both
and I'd like to mention that
we have arrived scheduled the last of
our Senate bills for two weeks from now
there is nothing scheduled for next week
because I want the subcommittees to
finish all the bills we have in process
and also the people that have said
I want to look into this one so next
week do your looking into get your
amendments and we will have the last
couple of three exactly Senate bills on
plus an exact session on every bill we
can
um
and then we will
hopefully be through for the season so
subcommittee chairs people that are
working on bills on their own please do
it
and um
we will all get to go on on summer
vacation early
priorities
precisely we've got to get our
priorities right
okay so I'm introducing the hearing on
Senate Bill
71 and I called Senator Carson
thank you very much Madam chair and good
morning to members of the House Edna
committee for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of Londonderry
Hudson and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
71 which seeks to establish a commission
to study workers compensation for
firefighter cancer disease and allows
for workers compensation for firefighter
cancer disease of all types Madam chair
um I'm sure you're aware that we have
passed legislation concerning
um firefighters and cancer
and the list of those cancers which are
available for compensation are already
in statute but what this legislation
tries to do is to provide better support
and care for firefighters who are
diagnosed with cancer and to study the
implementation of National annual cancer
screenings the Prima facial presumption
in the legislation acknowledges that
cancer and firefighters is often caused
by occupational exposure this provision
ensures that firefighters are eligible
for occupation cancer workers
compensation regardless of the form of
cancer and I'd like to point out because
I notice some of the members of your
committee are from my district and in
case anyone doesn't know
we have an issue in my district as well
as in other districts of pfas in our
water and many of my constituents are on
bottled water because they cannot drink
the water from their own Wells due to
contamination that's how serious this is
and I just didn't know if or make you
aware that pfas is located is currently
in firefighter protective gear so every
time they put on that protective gear
they are exposed to pfas and they have
no choice this is what they must wear to
protect themselves and quite frankly
Madam chair they're being exposed to
that pfas contamination
um currently our current law does not
include cancers such as brain cancer
stomach cancer mouth cancer
testicular cancer malignant melanoma
colon cancer Hodgkin's lymphoma and
female reproductive cancers which are
all commonly found in firefighters what
this Commission
establishes in legislation will study
the prevalence of cancer among
firefighters the benefits of early
detection and the costs of optional
yearly cancer screening programs as seen
in other states
specifically Massachusetts and New
Jersey
um
Madam chair at this point I will
terminate I will end my my uh my
testimony I will try to answer any
questions I'll make sure to pass in a
pink card so you have it for your
records and thank you all very much for
your time and your consideration this
morning
foreign yes thank you Senator I do have
one question sure why do we need to
study
the
the benefits of of cancer screenings
when we know that they work if on Camp
cancers that
do have indications or that can be
screened for
thank you I believe that's fairly well
known in the medical field that that's
useful
thank you madam chair it's my
understanding that
this screening process is not currently
in statute and part of the study would
be to make that decision whether or not
to include it in statute I could be
wrong there are folks here who are much
more involved in this issue than I am
but I agree with you completely
pre-screening I think is critical that
it should happen but I think we all know
that there are some folks that will find
themselves experiencing symptoms and
they won't
get looked at but if we say look you've
got to go through pre-screening I think
that might be the reason why it's there
and they want to look at it so I'm okay
with that
thank you other questions for the
Senator Senator Grodin the neighbor
thank you
um in the bill I believe you mentioned
that there is
now going to be workman's workman's
compensation won't be limited to the
type of cancer correct so where does it
say that I see that it's been stricken
from lines five to eight
in the bill
but I don't is there someplace else
where it says that they'll receive
compensation I don't see that in here so
um thank you I the copy that I have is
introduced
um I don't believe if it was stricken it
was probably stricken in house finance
excuse me Senate Finance I don't have
that copy all I have is as introduced
I'm sorry yes this ad is the version as
introduced okay
um
to do this one we have I don't think it
was I think
I think this section is in the workers
comp section and it does say in here
there shall exist Prima facial
presumption the cancer disease the
firefighter is occupationally closed I'm
so sorry and so all it does is remove
the limitation I was
okay if I had just read the line above
where it says workman's compensation it
would have been helpful thank you you're
welcome thank you thank you for that
safe representative Lucas because I was
a little confused there because I didn't
see that okay representing the baby bear
Madam chair logistical I just read the
same thing and thought it was excluding
what Senator Carson had just detailed
out so I missed it too thank you
all right we will have remedial reading
classes next week representative Simon
thank you madam chair I think my
question was pretty much answered but I
just wanted to clarify uh Senator and
thank you for taking my question this
bill does two things it establishes as a
study committee and it also
um institutes the presumption that any
cancer that is ever found in any
firefighter is based in the work
is is um
occupationally
correct you are correct sorry I couldn't
come up with the last word but thank you
that's okay no no you're you're exactly
correct it does establish the commission
um to study the compensation for
firefighter cancer disease and it allows
for workers compensation for firefighter
so not just for all types though correct
there will be a presumption that the
cancer that they had is the result of
their occupation correct okay thank you
well I trust there aren't any smoking
firefighters around because that would
um
I mean there are many known cases where
other than
exposure to contaminants I mean you
mentioned melanoma
uh it's representative baldosaro for
example developed melanoma I would I
would say that's not related to his
exposure to toxic substances due to his
excessive toasting
well I think Madam chair I I'm on good
ground to say representative baldosaur
is really
um the epitome of a sun worshiper
yes but it's some worshiping is known to
cause cancer and I
I would hope that the um
the workers comp board would take that
into and those those kind of things into
consideration when saying it's
caused but okay thank you any uh
representative Dolan
thank you madam chair um
very very sympathetic to the issue with
firefighters uh as the senator uh
brought up but I had a process question
in my second life is my committee on
commissions
um would an option be to hand this back
to HHS for them to study this issue
within their own committee
this is a new commission this bill is
not going to any other committee we're
stuck with it
um in fact now that I'm looking at it
Madam chair I think you've got a problem
okay
section two which is the study committee
takes place
take effect in November
the repeal in Section 3 takes place on
Passage
so
is that what you meant to do
um
Madam chair I will leave that up to you
thank you we'll we'll deal with it but
so you're appealing basically you're
repealing commission before it's founded
okay good makes it much easier for the
committee on commissions
okay representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair
um and thank you senator for taking my
question as the senator probably knows I
was a firefighter for 35 years and what
the senator believed that
early in my career was uh
reclining uniform requirement that we
wore white skivvies you know t-shirts
and everything else so which we did
and I used to have to throw them out
after every single fire because you
can't get to sit out of them you know so
I often wondered what was getting into
my skin so therefore besides the pifa's
uh pffas and everything else we do
breathe through the skin I know you may
not be technically you know Savvy as far
as the medical profusion and everything
else but until the firefighter gets back
to the station and have a chance and
most fire departments have that now
decontamination but until that point you
got you know this stuff is right on your
skin would I be correct in assuming that
thank you for the question yes you would
be representative as well as any
chemical that was used to put out the
fire would also be on your skin and I
believe that's why melanoma was included
um in in that because we we
automatically make the assumption that
melanoma is caused because of an
overexposure to the Sun but there are
other reasons why an individual would
have melanoma and I think that's why
requiring early screening and or an
annual screening is you can catch that
way ahead of time before it has a chance
to spread to an individual's lymph nodes
and cause problems elsewhere
you're welcome okay represent Gerhard
and then Lucas thank you madam chair
in 2000 this is related just follow me
for once okay in 2008 California started
putting up cell towers on the fire
departments and there was immediate
within a week the firemen were
experiencing memory loss um
at UNH Ken Chamberlain was commissioned
through the governor in both uh chambers
of the legislature it's the head of
Wi-Fi and cellular radiation commission
that actually they released like a 380
page report but it's just interesting
inside of this health
within a week they developed unusual
symptoms of headaches fatigue insomnia
memory loss after while firefighters in
stations with adjacent cell towers were
found aftergotten CPR or became lost
responding to a fire call in the city
they grew up in
so my point is in my town There's A Fire
there's a cell tower right by the fire
department and they claim it's okay
because it's not permanently occupied
but I'm just concerned would you would
your commission also look into this
because there's been studies with
schools having these towers up and
children developing brain cancer and so
forth
is that something this commission would
be involved in studying since it's
affecting them as well as everyone else
thank you for the question
um the way that I read it that they
would be discussing all types of
diseases or cancer so if someone wanted
to bring that up I would think that the
commission would entertain that
information as well all right thank you
you're welcome
all right um I thought I heard you say
that there was in statute a list of
cancers currently that are considered uh
work related for firemen where where is
that
um I don't remember exactly
representative where they're located I
just remember that legislation was
passed a few years ago where certain
types of cancers were specified in
statute
um so I I wouldn't be able to tell you
exactly where it is I'm sure that the
folks that are going to be coming up
behind me would be able to answer that
question better than I could follow up
excuse me Mr Greenland if you could
check and find out where that list is
for us we'd appreciate it
the reason I ask is that I'm wondering
if there's a conflict because of
somewhere in statute it lists a specific
list of cancer types that are considered
um occupation related for firemen
um you know would that still have an
effect even if um you know this section
here were struck out that was my concern
thank you very much for your question
representative
um the commission if you deem to pass it
will do its work and hopefully there
will be legislative findings and
legislative recommendations and if that
means filing a piece of legislation to
amend any existing statute to expand
that list that would be within the
purview of the commission to make that
recommendation and if that
recommendation is ma is made by any
member of this committee please include
me as a co-sponsor uh Senator the
problem is that
the first section applies no matter what
the commission does and it simply
deletes
um
basically it says that list is
irrelevant because any type of cancer is
considered to be covered
so I'm I agree that we're going to have
to look at what's going on in the other
statutes before we do something like
that Madam chair I would agree with with
you on that
the commission will do its work and if
the commission decides well all cancers
might be a little too much
um we're gonna
look at what we already have in statute
and we're going to add a couple things
to it again that has to be done
statutorily so I guess you can say I'm
trying to cover all bases
because we don't you don't know what a
commission will find and they will do
the work follow-up representative yeah
I'm I mean because of that and it looks
like the details this might come out of
the commission I'm wondering if
at this point although I'm sympathetic
because getting rid of of section one
might make sense and let the commission
decide what's the right thing to do and
then have future legislations that's
you know interesting comment we'll take
it up in the executive session
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair and follow up along the same lines
with representative Lakers but your
intention here of this particular bill
is to look at all cancers in other words
when Dupont invented Nomex which is you
know contaminated with pifas and
firefighters are now wearing this they
were selling that as a life safety
enhancement to Firefighters who knew 30
years ago that it would cause these type
of cancers of firefighters so we have to
be a little bit more open-minded uh and
that's what your intention is with this
bill what may not be cancerous now we
may find other products coming down
through invention or whatever trying to
increase the safety may actually be
doing more harm than good to 500 suits
that's your intention yes
um just rub representative just I mean
for general knowledge a few years we had
legislation dealing with the types of
foam that deals with putting out
chemical fires that the the exposure
um was extremely toxic for firefighters
and we did address that particular issue
and in the at the time that the foam was
first
used or and created it was look this is
for a specific purpose but then we find
out it's contaminating our water and our
ground as well as affecting the
firefighters that are using it so now I
I don't exactly remember what we what
happened but I do know that we pass
legislation dealing with that because we
felt that not only the firefighters
needed to be protected
um the environment needed to be
protected from this chemical that was
sold to us as being essential and it was
going to put out really horrible
chemical fires
okay thank you are there any other
questions for the senator
seeing none I would like to say you're
extremely optimistic in thinking that a
15 person commission can be appointed
and actually accomplished something in
six months Madam chair I have the most
faith in all of your ability to deal
with this and every member of the house
if they're assigned they're going to do
their job and they're going to do a good
job
thank you thank you oh and by the way we
have kind of like an informal rule in
the Senate if you uh propose a
commission you get to serve on it so
um if you should deem to pass this the
Senate I will be the Senate member so
thank you very much for letting Senator
Susie Rosenwald and Abbas off the hook
I'm letting them all off the hook no
there's two senators so oh well we'll
I'll find someone else to work with me
thank you madam chair for the record I'm
Mike Rollo I'm the director of
government relations for the American
Cancer Society cancer Action Network in
New Hampshire and Vermont and I thought
for sure I would be going last because I
thought all the firefighters would be
going first because they'd have better
information for you but here I sit and I
am here in support of section two we
don't have uh we don't have a position
on section one ma'am uh just section two
the study which seems to be getting the
most attention this afternoon as well
um
we um much of our surprise when I was
looking at titles of the bill and and
tracking it when it was finally printed
I noticed that my organization was uh
going to be a member of this commission
so I thought we'd better we better pay
even more attention to this and we'd be
happy to help
um has been listening to to Senator
Carson's testimony and then the
questions the first question that you
yourself raised Madam chair was
well we all know that early detection
and prevention is important and it works
I mean I don't think anyone is
questioning that I mean we all
understand that
um
and it's true
um that um
testing is very important
um and you won't get any argument out of
us
but I think what's really important if
you go down the list of all the other uh
potential duties of this commission if
you go down to line seven I'm sorry I'm
on page two by the way if you go down to
line seven that's uh letter F and I
didn't bring my glasses but you know
because I've only been doing this for
over a decade but
um the existence and access to potential
third-party vendors to provide cancer
screenings and early detection for
firefighters that goes hand in hand with
the health benefits of early detection
which is uh letter C line one
um there are tests that are being
developed currently and there's more in
the pipeline that are able to do things
that current testing can only dream of
currently if you go get a mammogram it's
testing for one type of cancer if you go
get a colonoscopy it's testing for we're
looking for one type of cancer there are
tests being developed there's one and
now that I'm sitting here I'm drawing a
blank on what is actually the name of it
the commercial name of it but the test
being developed through
Mass General down in Boston that's a
blood test that is looking at screening
that that Mass General is partnering
with communities within Massachusetts I
know whether than fire service but I'm
sure that the folks from the fire
service behind me can probably we'll
probably speak to this as well
um they're used they're they're they're
they're they're they're testing this as
a means of doing early detection for for
cancers that we have no test for
currently commercial tests for currently
so why do we need a commission to look
at whether or not early detection is
important because we already know it's
important because there are options
coming that may not be commercially
available at the moment but may be
coming soon very soon that you might
want to be looking at and investigating
and perhaps there are opportunities for
a New Hampshire Community to be part of
the the tests that are ongoing now I
mean I don't know that there I don't
want to speak for those research
hospitals
yeah pardon me that are doing the
research currently but I mean there
could be opportunities out there so I um
I for one don't know if I want to spend
my entire summer home by doing this I
mean I I will do it because it's very
important work I don't mean to make
light of this it's very important work
but um
um there is a lot of work that needs to
be done
every single one of these letters are
listed here isn't something that's
important that needs to be studied so
that's why this study is important
that's why you would want to consider
adding one more additional study to the
very long list of
studies that you're considering
mothballing
pardon me excuse me
um I understand the the
overwhelming desire to get rid of and
not and perhaps add to the very long
list of commissions that need to be
mothballed I get that this is one of
those that um that needs to be
decommissioned before it's commissioned
this is an issue that's long overdue
this is um I think every time you look
at the news or read a newspaper it seems
like we're learning about another
firefighter in our towns that has
developed a cancer
um I think back to over a decade ago to
the city of Portsmouth there was a young
firefighter who had developed a breast
cancer that um they didn't think was
related to her service I think they now
know that it was you know 20 I actually
do the math now 28 years ago my father
died of colon cancer
um he smoked for 50 something years and
everyone said well he didn't die of lung
cancer so it had nothing to do with his
smoking we now know that colon cancer
stomach cancer and a whole Hood bladder
cancer these are all affected by smoking
we didn't know that years ago
representative
um I remember it was you madam chair
brought up about melanoma and our dear
friend former representative beldazaro
and his his love of tanning well and
then representative O'Brien brought up
the the pfaffs and some of the Foams and
and the gear that he used to wear
we now know that there's a connection
between some melanoma the melanomas and
some of those those chemicals that he
was exposed to as a career firefighter
that we might not have known a few years
ago so it's an evolving science cancer
it's not a static science so
I don't want to belabor this point but
this study commission is one that I
think you really do want to embrace and
and as much as I might not want to spend
my summer and fall on this building
either I think it's one that we gotta
have to do and I'm happy to take
questions man thank you are there
questions
okay seeing none very good thank you
foreign
members of the committee
good morning uh if I could I'm going to
I've submitted some written testimony
um I'm going to give my verbal testimony
this morning and then I hope to clear up
some of uh the questions that you had uh
Senator Carson
first I'd like to uh thank Senator
Carson for her continued advocacy for
the health and safety of firefighters
she is astonish advocate for for us and
our membership my name is Brian rill and
I serve as the president of the
professional firefighters from New
Hampshire I'm also a captain for the
city of Portsmouth Fire Department
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire represents 42 local unions and
approximately 2 000 active and retired
professional firefighters and paramedics
across the granite state
there's a preeminent firefighter
organization in New Hampshire we
advocate for the health and safety of
the brave men and women that protect the
citizens of this great state I'm here to
testify and support as you can imagine
of Senate bill 71.
research conducted by the National
Institute for occupational safety and
health shows that firefighters have a 14
higher risk of dying from cancer than
the general population
in fact occupational cancer recently
surpassed heart attack as the leading
cause of line of duty deaths in the fire
service
in 2019 more than 75 percent of the
names added to the International
Association of firefighters Fallen
Firefighter Memorial were members who
died from occupational cancer
it's no secret that firefighting is an
inherently dangerous profession
firefighters lay their lives on the line
day in and day out to protect the lives
and property of complete strangers
oftentimes they're rewarded with a
cancer diagnosis for their efforts
in 2018 New Hampshire took a huge step
in advocating for and protecting their
firefighters by passing Senate Bill 541
which provides presumptive cancer
coverage for occupational cancer
this legislation laid the foundation for
comprehensive cancer coverage for
firefighters in the state of New
Hampshire and Senate Bill 71 is an
attempt to build upon this Foundation
if passed Senate Bill 71 would expand
the presumptive cancer coverage to be
inclusive of all cancers
you heard Senator Carson testify this
morning as to some of the cancers that
aren't currently covered
uh under our current statute
current law states that occupational
cancer must be a type which may be
caused by the exposure to heat radiation
or a known carcinogen as defined by the
international Agency for research on
cancer I heard a question asked this
morning as to where that list was found
in statute it is in fact a document
under the international Agency for
research on cancer that is cited in this
statute so that can be identified
through through research from this
agency I will say the way that they've
structured this is a multi-tier
structure to say that firefighters are
more susceptible to being diagnosed with
certain types of cancer under a tier one
and then there's a tier two where
they're less likely and so on and so
forth this has created a problem with
presumptive workers compensation as many
of our
members claims have been denied by by
current law as you heard Senator Carson
speak to excludes an extensive list of
cancers that I won't repeat uh for the
sake of of time here one that I do want
to identify
that is in fact covered but I think it
really supports the claim that
firefighters are at an increased risk of
developing cancer is malignant
mesothelioma
this is an extremely rare form of cancer
that affects the tissue that lines the
lungs stomach heart and other organs
it's a cancer in which firefighters are
129 percent more likely to die from than
the general population
this statistic makes it easy to
understand why the expansive expensive
coverage under this RSA is so critical
to our firefighters
and as the second part of this
legislation States it would establish a
commission to study the implementation
of these cancer screenings for
firefighters
early diagnosis of as we've heard
discussed this morning of cancer focuses
on detecting symptomatic patients as
early as possible nobody can deny that
early detection is key and critical
early diagnosis improves cancer outcomes
by providing care at the earliest
possible stage and is therefore an
important Public Health strategy
cancer screenings on the other hand
which is what we're just discussing this
morning are summarized slightly
differently
the World Health Organization defines a
screening as a presumptive
identification of unrecognized disease
in an apparently healthy asymptomatic
population by means of tests
examinations or other procedures that
can be applied rapidly and easily
compared to early diagnosis cancer
screenings are a distinct and more
complex Public Health strategy that
requires additional resources
infrastructure and coordination
this is not a strategy which can be
developed overnight and it is one in
which requires planning research and
collaboration
this is why this commission to identify
this structure and the processes of such
an elaborate program are especially
crucial
the importance of this portion of Senate
Bill 71 cannot be overstated
as a routine cancer screening program
would promote early detection and offer
potentially life-saving intervention for
firefighters while reducing long-term
costs to employers and risk pool
providers
again the World Health Organization in
research states that the cost of health
care for patients who receive early
cancer diagnosis is two to four times
less than that
for those who have an advanced diagnosis
this is significant when we consider the
financial burden for cancer related
Health Care is projected to surpass 246
although this legislation is Progressive
in its intent it should be noted that
other states have already implemented
screening programs similar to what we're
asking for and have had great success
Massachusetts and New Jersey were
mentioned Massachusetts screens
firefighters for prostate lung skin and
mouth cancer while New Jersey screens
for 11 different types of cancers
a quick Google search will show you that
similar programs exist in other states
including Colorado South Carolina and
California
most notably Vermont is nearing passage
of legislation similar to that of what
we're trying to push forward today and
in fact is being heard in the house and
committee today as well
this has received widespread support
from policy makers in Vermont
so when we discuss the importance of not
only including all cancers
the screening study commission is
incredibly important not only to figure
out how to develop such a complex
program but to figure out how to do so
and and remain
financially responsible in in getting a
program like this completed
so with that um
I would be happy to answer any questions
I I would ask Madam chair in hearing
your your question to Senator Carson uh
and as those the organization that
requested this bill be passed
um to give the commission some more time
and potentially move this date to
November of 2024 rather than 2023
um and and being respectful to
everyone's time
um and then the last thing I would touch
upon that was a question that was asked
uh is that just because all cancers
would be covered under the presumption
there are still
a number of safeguards in place to
ensure that uh the
the cancer is in fact job related
um Madam chair you mentioned smoking and
members that uh you you hope that
members don't smoke there is Provisions
in current statute that members need to
live a tobacco-free lifestyle
in addition just because there is
presumptive coverage that doesn't
necessarily mean that all cancers will
be covered
um under under the law it's just the
presumptive coverage moves the burden of
proof to the workers comp carrier rather
the employee
so once again thank you for your time
I'd be happy to answer any questions I
urge your support of this very critical
legislation okay I have a number of
questions uh first of all I understand
that near legal firefighters are
employed by municipalities
is that correct
correct and each municipality has its
own
health coverage of some sort for its
employees correct correct so is the
would be fair to say that one effect of
this bill will be to move all cancer
cases to workers comp and essentially
consolidate all of them under workers
comp
is that correct
I would say on its surface yes initially
if I make a cancer claim it would be it
would go under workers compensation but
it would be no different than any other
workers compensation claim
um a a
someone would look at it an adjuster
would look at this determine whether or
not
um it does meet the requirements of the
law and either approve the claim for
deny it and then move forward in that
process eventually these May Circle back
around to be covered under Health Care
okay so that's what you so that's what
you meant when you said that some claims
were workers comp claims were denied is
that they are now falling back on the
employers insurance
correct okay
okay
um I also had a question
um if cancer is that much of a concern
for firefighters
why aren't they taking the initiative to
get these cancer screenings
earlier and more often
because I mean that's what somebody who
has
you know an inherited risk for cancer
does is you start earlier and you do it
more frequently because they're more
likely to catch something is that not
common practice among the firefighters
so we are just like everyone else for
likely in this room are subject to what
our health care will cover
um for instance because we are at higher
risk we are eligible to receive
um
diagnostic testing like colonoscopies at
an earlier age than the general
population
however
depending on the type of screening or
tests that can be conducted but it tends
to be
a significant cost to that that in a lot
of cases your insurance provider does
interesting thank you representative
thank you madam chair
so on March 17th there was a one of the
local affiliates down in Natick
Massachusetts
they're instituting heart screenings for
Natick police through the fire
department police department and also
surrounding ones a 39 year old fell dead
from a heart attack so I'm just curious
as to do you see this expanding into the
other branches of public service because
there's there's health issues that we've
seen rise in unexplained deaths over
many different fields recently
so I'm just curious do you see that as a
future angle or is this simply for fire
department that's it
I can tell you I represent firefighters
um and my angle is cancer screenings for
firefighters
um I would love to see all public safety
personnel be protected to whatever their
um whatever they're most susceptible to
but I can tell you I you will not see me
come to you and ask you for legislation
for police officers or other Personnel
outside of the firefighters
okay other questions
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
I saw a study that was done that looked
at the time
um the time it takes to put out a fire
and how that's changed over the years
and the outcome is was that um fires
consume buildings much quicker today
than it did in Years Gone by and that
that's because of the chemicals in all
of the items in a building
that didn't used to be there do you know
if any my question to you is do you know
if there have been any studies as we
heard
um representative O'Brien talk about the
skin absorbing the toxins on the amount
of toxins
that uh are are put out in these fires
when all of the materials if we look in
this building these materials are not
natural materials they're chemical
materials and do we have there been
studies that have looked at that and the
impact that has on cancer to our
firefighters thanks for the question
representative uh I I will say yes and
and I can try and identify some of those
studies for you I don't have any of them
offhand what I will tell you is is you
hit the nail right on the head
um
you know many years ago
um uh
uh with Legacy construction as you
mentioned
materials used to build a house where
natural materials a lot of the furniture
that you would buy was not coated with
as many chemicals now everything that
burns within a residence
um has polycarbons in it which cause
cancer and then I and I heard identified
earlier was the pfas in our turnout gear
there is not a manufacturer out there
currently that manufactures protective
turnout gear are our protective
equipment that we wear to every fire
that does not have pfas chemicals in it
so we are going to put out
the the communities house fires
knowingly
um the the gear that we're using so that
representative true and then O'Brien
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I'm I'm trying to
understand the ramifications of section
one
of the bill
so
basically does this mean and I believe
you've already touched on it
that if a firefighter is diagnosed with
cancer
it is assumed
that that is a workman's compensation
compensation
claim
unless workers compensation
can prove it isn't by isn't isn't job
related
correct so under current statute
there is the presumption that a
definitive number of cancers
are
occupationally caused
and with that in order to debunk that
for lack of a better term
the insurance provider would have to
um show that that was not occupationally
caused maybe that's as simple as digging
into medical records to find that
someone is a pack a day smoker
um so that part of the statute would not
change it would just be inclusive of all
cancers
uh you're welcome
okay representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
brother for taking my question
um I know when the fire service was
supposed to be Jacks of all trades and
master all of them you know uh so I'm
gonna get into the pieces a little bit
here uh is that really relevant to this
Bill yes yes it is okay thank you
because the thing is I want to committee
to understand me Madam chair uh when
Dupont invented the Nomex and it came
out it was a boon to the industry we all
bought into it it was uh uh gonna you
know save us from getting burnt uh and
thermal Burns and everything
but many uh departments do have a policy
that firefighters must wear the
protective clothing before you know
going teams or two and everything
there's no other choice that is out
there for our firefighters to put on
this jacket or you know impregnated
material with what we come now to
understand the pifas uh that is harmful
to us am I correct and assuming that
thank you representative you're correct
and and we don't I think it's worth
noting we don't just wear that
protective Ensemble for structural fires
we're expected to uh and required to
wear them for uh motor vehicle accidents
hazardous materials events
um any uh poor weather events because it
has reflective material on it
um so in most cases when we go out on a
call we're required to wear that gear
okay thank you
and representative Simon
thank you madam I'm assuming that this
is going to come to my subcommittee so I
just want to make sure that I have the
relevant data
um following on representative O'Brien's
question is that statutorily required or
the fire departments themselves require
so thank you for your question uh fire
fire departments require it it's not in
statute okay and a quick follow-up
follow-up
um the other question that I had for you
is
do other groups have access to workman's
comp for cancer related incidences I'm
thinking about like minors who also have
high exposure to cancer or even nail
salon workers tend to have a very above
average
um exposure to cancer
um do you know whether this would is
unique to the fire department or do
other high-risk
jobs also have access to workman's comp
for cancer so I'm unaware of any
any other subgroups that have access to
this coverage I do know that
um
widely throughout the country
firefighters have presumptive coverage
for cancer
that's not to say that there are other
groups that are susceptible to it but
the research has certainly been there to
show that this is no longer anecdotal
that this is this is real life that
we're at a much higher risk okay thank
you
questions
all right thank you very much oh sorry
Peter
thank you madam chair
um so I apologize for being late I was
testifying on another bill in another
committee
um but if this issue has been raised
already I apologize again but uh several
years ago we had an issue with his
firefighting foam uh that's been raised
it has been raised yes okay uh but I in
in the course of uh I'll ask another one
then when I was on the Dover City
Council about 25 years ago I had the
opportunity to suit up when we were
investigating the cut their Council was
investigating these infrared cameras
that are so helpful in being able to to
be able to see even when a room is
filled with smoke
and I got an opportunity to suit up and
I know with a hat the whole thing
including the the oxygen tanks I believe
that that that's a very constricting uh
outfit to have one and it's quite heavy
so uh are there Alternatives uh to uh to
the the gear that's currently being worn
which are uh safer or
uh maybe not as constrictive I know this
this is this bill is very much about the
cancer aspect uh and from what
representable Brian's question I did
hear that you know the mandatory use of
this gear uh so
um could you answer the question I
raised thank you representative I will
answer this one quickly no
there are no alternatives thank you all
right all right thank you very much
turn your mic on please
here we go uh good morning thank you
madam chair members of the committee uh
my name is Larry best I represent the
New Hampshire Association of Fire Chiefs
as the president I'm also the fire chief
in the town of Salem uh president real
in front of me just spoke he covered a
lot of what I would have to say so I'm
not going to reiterate a lot of that
based upon the time for today however I
am here as a representative of New
Hampshire Fire Chiefs asking for support
on passing Senate Bill 71
back in 2018 when Senate Bill 541 was
passed that was step one in this step
two is what is currently written today
in Senate Bill 71 as the next logical
step moving it forward for cancer
coverage for firefighters
the risks associated with firefighting
they don't end when just the fire is
extinguished it's there's a lot that
goes with it later on exposures to
carcinogens um not only doing the job
but that gets in your gear and and as
representative O'Brien talked about gets
absorbed into your skin that's a very
real thing
representative gold I think talked about
the types of gases that are created in
in these new fires today from when I've
been doing this job for 31 years as a
full-time firefighter another four years
on top of that as a volunteer it's
completely changed from then and now
some of the things that we do towards
the end of a fire to determine what
level of protective equipment that we
need to wear we do air monitoring and we
monitor for hydrogen cyanide which is
often a gas that we find that has is
there because of the products that have
burnt during the fire so
with that said it is a very real thing
there are a number of cancers this bill
helps expand the coverage for those
cancers I think one of the other things
here that I'd just like to hit on real
quick is there's been quite a bit of
discussion about uh early screening and
detection and what you can do
to try and prevent cancer in my
department I I've we've had two cases
that we've lived one I would like to say
that it was found because they were
searching for cancer but it was actually
found early on I'm kind of trying to
figure out what the medical situation
was but it was still an early detection
of cancer that firefighter received
treatment and is continued on the job
today the second case and we're on we
weren't as fortunate it was it was very
late diagnosis on cancer and
unfortunately that firefighter passed
away from cancer so I think when you
talk about the law longevity of
firefighters health and wellness the
more that we can do for early screening
to determine if people have cancer
firefighters have cancer or not that's a
huge benefit to this and that's
something that
um
the study commission would would help
support and help give that information
to us and stuff so quickly just in
closing like I said uh president real
covered a lot of what I was going to
talk about uh the New Hampshire
Association of Fire Chiefs we
respectfully request that you vote to
pass Senate Bill 71 since it will help
those who receive a cancer diagnosis
while enabling the commission to develop
a more effective plan for early
detection of cancer in the future I'd be
happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
representative Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
knowing what I stated earlier I live in
a house that was built in 1827 it has no
chemicals in it my carpets are all wool
my curtains are all cotton or wool I
don't have any synthetic fibers in my
home my question to you is
knowing what we know what alternatives
and why
why do firemen put on cancer producing
clothing every day I think that many of
us sitting here are trying to understand
why we would have to study like isn't
prevention better than early detection
I'm trying to understand and I want to
be supportive so thank you for your
question
um as far as what can be done and
talking about Furnishings in particular
and and construction of houses that one
I don't know the answer to that that's a
industry-wide question that would have
to be dealt with that's above me
um as far as what can be done for
prevention on uh firefighters and and
reducing the risk of cancer we try and
do as much as we can with
decontamination and washing when we
return from calls but it's not 100
percent as far as I've there's been a
few questions about alternatives to the
type of gear that we wear there are not
any alternatives to the type of gear
that we wear right now I'm sure there's
there's studies that are going on but
right now there is no other choice
follow up thank you madam chair
so
um what is the benefit like if you know
you're putting clothing on it's going to
create cancer uh representative Gould
the advantage is that keeps you from
getting burnt to death
and that's what I wanted to hear I don't
think we've heard enough of that we've
heard a lot about what the damage it
does I don't think we've heard clearly
stated one I'm sure if I can help I'll
be glad to speak to the commission about
the committee about that because this is
something that I was involved with in my
previous life and one of the reasons why
firefighters wear this gear is because
it is the only thing that protects them
from getting burned
all right so we can talk about that but
it's not something that people
voluntarily do okay thank you but
without the gear we can't do our job we
can't go in the fires because the smoke
and the Heat and we get burnt thank you
very much that was important to be said
I think yes
representative Simon thank you madam
chair once again just for clarification
so obviously the reason for wearing the
gear into a fire I mean it seems pretty
self-evident but it sounded like
um firefighters also wear it to a bunch
of other kinds of calls is that correct
or is it just a fire so so there are
other types of calls um uh the president
real uh touched on a couple of those
would be a motor vehicle accident
um you wear it typically during a motor
vehicle accident
um sometimes you're not sure like if
there's spilled gasoline if there may be
a flash fire um so you need to have that
protective gear because of that there
may be a technical rescue incident where
there could be a flammable atmosphere so
you would need to wear your gear then
um we we try to limit in the sense of
not wearing it all the time but
obviously if we're in a situation where
there's a flammable atmosphere or
something and we're concerned that there
could be a fire then we would need to
wear the gear in those situations and
there's a whole array of different
scenarios of when that would occur
okay great thank you okay other
questions representative shua thank you
madam chair is it not true also that if
you're responding to say an automobile
accident uh this these uh turnout codes
include reflective gear that protect you
from being hit by another vehicle that's
passing by that is correct the gear does
have reflective striping on it to help
give us visibility when we're out in the
street we also do try and wear
reflective vests similar to what you
would see a construction worker wear as
well so in cases when we can do that and
it's safe and we're not in a flammable
atmosphere that gives us an alternative
to maintain that reflectiveness so we
can people can see us when we're in the
street
okay thank you other representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chair
I had occasion back when I lived in
Chicago about 45 years ago to be in a
neighboring apartment building where
there had been an apartment fire now the
fire fighters had knocked down the fire
without the building being destroyed but
uh the apartment itself was a you have
lots of experience the apartment itself
was the owners was really terrible so my
question is how much does the
respiratory deer that you wear a
protective against because you have the
oxygen and but so there must be filters
and so forth how how much danger are you
still exposed to from the
the chemicals that are produced by the
fire
so thank you for the question uh so as
long as we're wearing our self-contained
breathing apparatus respiratory wise
we're self-contained we we have our air
with us we're good there
um it's a matter of it's not only the
respiratory part it's the absorption
part Through Your Skin there's been a
number of studies that have shown the
absorption of the the carcinogens
through the through your skin there was
a several firefighters out of Rhode
Island I believe is Providence the
entire engine company four people had
cancer all in this area because it was
absorbed through the skin so if we wear
our respiratory wise as long as we have
our self-contained breathing apparatus
on at the time we're good absorption is
another component of this and then
there's also the component where I
talked about earlier when we go into the
overhaul phase of a fire where the the
main body of fire is knocked down we
have to go in and overhaul it make sure
it's completely out there's still
off-gassing that goal that is going on
at that point we do try and take
measures to protect ourselves
respiratory wise and that's where some
of the air monitoring comes in at that
point again but it's not a 100 percent
given that we're able to protect
ourselves
all right thank you thank you are there
all right I don't see any thank you for
your testimony
most people don't uh correct it when
they say Melissa thank you madam chair
um members of um good morning everyone
my name is Marissa Chase I represent the
New Hampshire Association for justice
which is a euphemism for the trial
lawyers we're here in support of Senate
Bill 71
um just requesting one little change
that I spoke to the medical society and
uh president rill about
um on page one line 25
um Jay an attorney appointed by the New
Hampshire Medical Society we would
respectfully request that be changed to
appointed by the New Hampshire
Association for justice should this bill
move forward that's in line with 2018
Senate Bill 553 which established an
oversight commission to look into
incidents of PTSD and workers comp part
of our organization includes a large and
active workers comp peer group where our
members represent claimants in workers
comp claims and I think that
knowledge base would be be really
helpful to any discussions that this
Commission
may have
I'm happy to take any questions and if
this study commission goes to a
subcommittee I'd be happy to bring a
lawyer who is well versed in workers
comp to answer any of those technical
questions
thank you that might be helpful it is
going to subcommittee
representative Dolan thank you
yes uh as you've been I thank you for
taking my question as you've been
following this this uh legislation
through the process uh do you are you
confused or
concerned that this wasn't taken up by
the senate in the in its HHS role and it
ended up in the in the Edna uh
role for the senator and house that I'm
a little confused as to why this didn't
get uh managed to the HHS uh with with
the ex with the expertise is probably
greater
um I don't believe that's her
her decision that's the decision of the
president of the Senate and the speaker
of the house as to what committees the
bill goes to
I I would just note representatives in
looking at the um the legislative
history on 2018 Senate Bill 553 that
established the other oversight
commission I talked about with workers
comp and PTSD and First Responders
um that bill actually went to Commerce
so
we all get to get to the fun of dealing
with these things all right are there
any other questions
all right seeing none thank you
are there any is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on Senate bill 71.
all right not seeing any I will close
the public hearing and refer this to the
foreign
um
Senator Susie I'm opening the hearing on
Senate bill 72.
thank you very much Madam chairman
members of the committee for the record
I'm Donna soucy I represent Senate
District 18 which is comprised of the
town of Litchfield and five Wards in the
city of Manchester
um I just want to start by giving you a
little context about this bill because
it did go to the Senate Edna committee
but it's not the typical credentialing
or licensing issue that this committee
deals with because it's not the state or
government entity that's doing the
licensing in this case it's
credentialing by insurers
so with that context Senate Bill 72
proposes to make minor changes to the
provider credentialing verification
procedures that are required by law for
Health Care carriers uh to follow when
credentialing Health Care Professionals
72 attempts to avoid delays in patients
seeking care when their provider is only
changing their office location or making
a change in practice ownership
this bill would not change any
requirements to notify the carrier of
these changes it just ensures that
there's no disruption in the network
participation status of a credentialed
provider with the carrier
Senate Bill 72 also gives the
Commissioner of Insurance Authority it
would have given him authority to
resolve disputes but essentially what we
want to ensure is that if you or going
to a doctor if you have an established
relationship with the practice and a
change regarding that Physician's
relationship with your insurance carrier
is made that the insurer make the change
promptly or notify the person uh the
provider of the reason for any delay or
inactivity
if I can give you a more concrete
example because I know this sounds a
it's a lot simpler than it sounds but
there's individual who had long
established relationship with the
physician in New Hampshire City and it
turned out that the Physicians practice
was acquired by a hospital so that's
considered a change in ownership it took
quite a bit of time for that physician
to be recrudentialed so to speak with
the provider in the interim the patient
was uncertain of whether or not the
provider would still be part of their
Network and they were on a maintenance
drug that required regular blood testing
for it to continue the concern was if
they did seek the services through their
physician and the physician was then
deemed to have no longer been part of
the network they may have been on the
hook for a substantial cost so all this
is trying to do is to ensure that
providers
um
have those requests made in a very
timely fashion
thank you I
on line nine it says the commissioner
shall record complaints is that the
insurance commissioner that is correct
Madam chair okay because
that's not one of our normal statutes as
I said I um I I found it curious when
the bill was assigned to Senate Edna and
not Commerce and it appears that whoever
assigned just followed suit here in the
house I you know I certainly
seeing the faces around this table and
quite certain of competent resolution of
the legislation regardless of whether
it's here or the Commerce Committee so I
would appreciate your consideration and
passage of the bill okay thank you are
there any questions representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chair
welcome Senator uh so it says in line
nine the commissioner shall accept uh
and obviously uh I'm wondering whether
that's too specific
um
because
the commissioner ain't going to be the
one accepting 99 of the time right it's
going to be some one of his subordinates
or some specific you know the legal
office whatever uh and I'm wondering
whether that question was raised in the
Senate so the the language on line nine
actually is fairly standard throughout
the statute Throughout the chapter the
commissioner by definition is the
individual but also
um that language is used fairly
consistently I know this is a chapter
that you don't often do work in but
there's also someone here from the
Department who could probably further
address that because there is a standard
complaint procedure for right I think
you really answered the question because
to the degree it's standard language
it's standard language
okay thank you very much
other questions
seeing none thank you man
hello I'm Deborah Cates
um and I have not spoken before
something like this so excuse me but I
am a practice manager for Pembroke
Wellness Center which is an independent
practice
who does credentialing and actually the
practice was sold to an independent
doctor on December 1st I could speak
passionately on this bill because I am
in the process of trying to credential
the position that purchased the practice
it is April
and she is still not credentialed with
some insurances due to the fact with
delays on that with inability to get
um some insurances to correspond with me
in a timely manner this particular
physician just moved over from the
Concord area to the one town over
basically she was already credentialed
with insurances and I have one
particular one and I won't I guess I
can't name names but literally I can
only email this one I call the provider
representative and I'm told that there
is no credentialing department or no
representative I can speak to I can only
email and I email an email and I can't
get anywhere to credential this does
affect patients which would be people
like yourself who I was told I started
October 21st to credential her because
she was purchasing the practice December
1st because my husband retired
um
and these patients were seen in December
their bill still is not paid they are on
the hook for the bill they were
previously our patient this is like a
snowballing effect so it is you know she
was credentialed with this particular
insurance company previously and is now
not credentialed even though I was told
December October 21st I sent the email I
got a thing back saying if we need any
more information from you we'll let you
know
I didn't
they didn't need any more information to
my knowledge because they didn't say we
needed anything so I thought she was all
set patients were seen December 1st
I got paid by said insurance company
from some of the plans so I thought all
of the plans were all set apparently not
all the plans are all set this one
particular plan where I'm not being paid
on it affects about six patients and I
cannot speak to a representative so I
have spent calling the insurance
commissioner last week I have been at my
wit's end because I can't talk to a live
body to get this doctor credentialed so
I mean I would love this to be passed
because 30 days is reasonable for a
doctor that is already credentialed with
the insurance company previously all she
well thank you for sharing that that
horrifying story and I'm I'm glad it is
only one Insurance some plans that one
insurance company that are quite this
bad I would hope that most of them are
better
I'm dealing with four that she is still
not credentialed with it is not just one
thank you for clarifying I'm
sufficiently uh
impressed by your your diligence
any questions
representative blackis
thank you um
so I guess if let's say this uh this
becomes law and a problem like this
reoccurs or this one continues I suppose
um so it sounds like the remedy would be
a complaint to the insurance insurance
commissioner
um you know I'm not familiar again with
how the insurance commissioner works in
the whole department what what kind of
action can they and are they likely to
take that would actually fix this
problem uh we have a representative from
the commissioner who will be speaking to
us later withdraw the question for the
moment
any other questions
okay thank you very much
could we have the spelling of the last
witness's last name
k-a-i-t-z
foreign
thank you
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee for the record Paula
minahan Senior vice president state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all our hospitals in the
state as well as our specialty hospitals
acute and Specialty the hustle
Association is in strong support of
Senate Bill 72 and we do appreciate
Senator Susie sponsoring this bill as
well as all the co-sponsors with
bipartisan support this bill as stated
amends the provider credentialing
statute under the insurance statute RSA
420j and again just slightly as Senator
soucy um has indicated and again I will
not read my testimony because you have
it it is
again ensuring that the patients do not
experience unnecessary delays as Miss
Cates just identified that is really
what we're trying to resolve and our
hospitals own many practices and as
Senator Susie said they go maybe from
One hospital practice to a different
hospital little practice and but they
remain credentialed or in network those
hospitals are still in network with the
carriers so these are not complex fully
credentialed processes these are pretty
straightforward and again I think um
Miss Cates did a really good job of
explaining in um in in reality what
actually happens and the problem is the
patients are caught in the middle and
that's what we are trying to resolve so
the bill that you have in front of you
was amended we did work with the
Department of Insurance as well as the
carriers I know that they're here I
don't know if they plan to speak but my
understanding is that everyone was in
agreement with the language as
as amended in the Senate and we are
appreciative of their engagement and
willingness to to amend the bill and I
am happy to answer any questions but I
do um strongly support this bill and
hope you will as well thank you thank
you are there any questions
representative
Madam chair thank you I have a legit
logistical question how come this would
be in a FN Bill Financial like where's
where's that tied to I didn't understand
that
uh because
somebody got who was involved thought
that it might cause the insurance
department a lot of trouble and expense
apparently the insurance department
responded to the request for fiscal note
saying no problem
it's that's not that uncommon
okay anyone else
all right seeing none thank you thank
you
turn your mic on please
there you go oh
there we go thank you madam chair my
name is Alex Feld Babel I'm an insurance
company examiner with the insurance
department and part of my responsibility
is to address
legislation and legislative committees
on various Health Care issues so this
insurance department has no position on
this billboard we were very comfortable
with the language
that as it has been amended by the
Senate I had proposed a certain language
and that is incorporated here
um
the one question that came from the
committee was what is
um the process that the insurance
commissioner would use for enforcement
if there's a violation essentially the
issue is
um violation of the timeliness standards
for processing these credentialing
applications and it's 30 days for
primary care physicians and 45 days for
specialists
um and uh it's our experience that we I
mean we already receive a fair number of
complaints from Health Care Providers
about untimely processing of
credentialing applications and the
department even put out a bulletin to
carriers last year to remind them of The
Importance of Being in compliance with
the timeliness standards for
credentialing especially these days when
there is
um
a crisis in access to Providers
especially certain kinds of providers
like Mental Health Providers
nurses and and others it's important
when there are providers who are
available to get them credentialed
properly
there was also
um
what
oh just the question about the reference
to the commissioner it's uh that's
typical knowledge statutes it's um like
Louis XIV Leta Samoa
um the commissioner is the department
um and that's just the way all all of
title 37 is worded
um just a little bit of context I think
might also help here
this law for 20 J
um is a model law developed through the
National Association of insurance
Commissioners and it's in place in many
states it came about in order to address
the regulation of managed care which
really came into
predominance in the 1990s and Managed
Care essentially means health coverage
that's offered through a network where
you the covered person are incentivized
or Limited in some way to getting your
care from that network of providers
and this portion of the law requires
Health carriers to make sure that
everyone in their network is
um
uh
qualified to be delivering care to those
covered persons so there's a lot that
the health care has to do
um in this section of Statute they have
to make sure that uh the provider is
graduated from professional school
um has a license
um check the malpractice history check
the general practice history
and there's a list of
about
13 items that the carrier has to carry
out so it's not an easy process and
there's been a lot of policy discussion
over the years over how we can satisfy
the on the one hand the need to make
sure providers are qualified that are in
the network on the other hand to make
sure everything is timely done so that
our whole healthcare system isn't bogged
down so that's been the issue and this
modification
um you know would address that in some
limited way and we're also comfortable
with the provision that says that the
insurance commissioner will take
complaints from providers and bring
enforcement actions
um
for violations and we have
a whole menu of options when we bring in
enforcement action we can conduct what's
called a market conduct exam it's like
an audit and then have findings from
that which could lead to a fine or a
corrective action plan and continued
monitoring so we have
um
sort of a whole menu
of options for enforcement including
ultimately pulling a company's license
if they're particularly intransigent
so I'd be happy to answer any questions
that probably I know a little too long
okay
Mongolian
thank you you mentioned a 30 days and 45
days but the bill I see before us only
has 30 days so
yeah the um
I think what it is
um
is
the original
application has to be processed in 30
days of your primary care provider and
within 45 if you're a specialist but
then if you have to be recrudentialed
because of an event such as you're
bought out by another practice then that
deadline is 30 days ah thank you
represent goalie
thank you madam chair
in the
issues we're having with health care and
finding enough practitioners in that
can you tell me why
it would take so long to credential
someone if they're just moving from one
practice to another if they're already
in network why does it take so long to
the providers say oh we're already
covering them under this health care
provider
sure we'll carry along the patients and
go over to the next why why is it such a
process yeah that's a good question but
I think the reason that we're accepting
this uh 30-day deadline instead of
anything longer is that for
recrudentialing it ought to be the case
that not
the whole you don't have to go down the
whole list that you perhaps have already
confirmed that this provider is licensed
and just because of a change in
ownership
you know you don't have to recheck that
so it it ought to be easier
so could we shorten the time frame from
30 days
um
I uh would think it would be important
to hear from the industry
um on that question before making a
decision like that
I have a question how often does a
provider need to be re-certified
assuming no change in address or
whatever the statue says every three
years
credentialed yeah
thank you
what we've heard from and we just
received some testimony about the
difficulty or the length of time to get
somebody credentialed thinking of it in
reverse if you wanted to take away
somebody's credentials is it this a
um I doubt
I mean I'm not an expert on the whole
credentialing question I have
participated over the
decades and various committees
study committees that looked at the
issue
um
so I think I'm qualified enough to say
that in that context if you find one
issue
um
that is uh indicating that a particular
provider should not be credentialed then
yeah actually you stop when you find the
first big problem fair enough okay other
questions
representative true
thank you madam gee I've got I've got a
really complicated question here oh I
love those what is it what is a change
of status
oh
um
I think uh
the primary example
um
that we've been that gave rise to this
bill was an experience with the provider
um
being acquired by another provider
um and
the other
um experience that was referred to when
this bill was over in the Senate I think
is a provider changing location
[Music]
and taking a look at the
location of the practice is an element
of what you have to consider in
credentialing so those are two examples
that I can think of
go yes follow up thank you madam chair
so
um
if Dr true uh Works uh in his own
practice in uh
Hanover
and I moved my practice to Manchester
I would probably have to get re
credentialed from the insurance company
from the
yes I'm thinking that I'm I'm referring
apparently that was the case of the the
person that uh Miss cat Cates talked
about that they moved and they had to be
re-credentialed
if I could follow up just one more thank
you madam chair
so if if a doctor in state is moving
from point A to point B with a different
address they get 30 days to get
reconjentioned
how long does it take for a doctor
coming in from California who know New
Hampshire knows nothing about how long
would it take them to get to
credentialed
a GP yeah I think it would
um I mean the same 30 days deadline
applies
thank you representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am chair since this seems
to be much more of a trend or of the new
State of Affairs
is this process being improved so that
we get a better result in a faster time
because you know
we're going to be dealing with it seems
like even with this statute we're going
to be dealing with this situation all
the time now is that not the case yeah
it is the case that it continues to be
an important issue the department just
uh concluded
um two mental health parity examinations
uh where we're looking at
um some of the major carriers in the
state and whether they treat health
coverage for mental health in parity
with medical Surgical and one of the
issues in that examination
that we focused on was
encouraging the carriers to streamline
their credentialing process for mental
health providers
thank you
okay any other questions
thank you very much for the information
and I would hope that the 30 days is a
maximum and not a an average because it
seems like an awfully long time to
process a change of address
even the post office does it faster
all right I have a card from someone
nhms ads
yes you left your name off sir
details
my name is David Hutton h-u-t-t-o-n and
I am the New Hampshire mgma legislative
liaison mgma stands for medical group
management association we're actually a
strictly a volunteer group right now the
New Hampshire chapter has about a
hundred members we represent primarily
physician practices including both
hospital and hospital-based practices
and there's a National Organization too
that actually has about uh sixty
thousand Medical Practice administrators
and represents 350 000 Physicians
and I'm also represent the New Hampshire
Medical Society and that I'm on the
board of the medical society I am not a
doctor as the legislative liaison for
mgma and I'm a practice manager I manage
a GI practice on the Seacoast that I've
done for the last 11 years that has 17
providers right now including 11
Physicians and
physician assistants and nurse
practitioners so I'm here wearing Three
Hats but I would tell you that all three
of these entities have the same concerns
that have brought me here and which
affect us as well as our patients in
many practices are concerned with some
ensure responsiveness or lack thereof
regarding the subject of this bill
and that's responding to us regarding
provider updates and additions and to
the current requirements of the law and
they would we would like to see these
changes put in place so that the law
would have more teeth to assist us in
getting this done uh why is this
important to us well when we when we
offer
Physicians and other providers
employment agreements we have to give
them we have to give them a lot of
notice before they can come on board if
they're licensed in New Hampshire we
would use 90 to 120 days
because of the insurer process if
they're not licensed yet in New
Hampshire we have to extend it further
so they can get a license with the Board
of Medicine or the Board of Nursing
whichever board so my particular
practice when I joined it 11 years ago
had about nine Physicians now we have 17
providers why have we grown so much it's
because there's a need and the GI needs
in the state have grown tremendously
everybody we have joined us is very very
busy and if anything the big issue right
now is getting patients in to see
providers so I think it creates a real
deficit in the clinical situation when
people can't get in to see you I can
tell you as someone who deals with this
as a practice manager we have a lot of
unhappy patients when they cannot be
so the insurers
um
the problem we have and I think I want
to emphasize this is not all insurers
some insurers are very good some
insurers if I had a billing person here
would tell you are terrible and some are
in between so it really varies a lot and
all we're looking from them is timely
response to our applications for
providers and we have people who we send
in an application we have to contact
them to find out if they received it we
have to remind them a couple of weeks
later that we haven't heard whether they
acknowledge they've received it and the
process goes on and on and often we have
someone who has to kind of be on top of
this to check with a particular insurer
to find out where they are because we
cannot schedule our new providers within
particular insurers until we know that
the services are covered by that insurer
and um the the I think the key word is
it's very very frustrating and it it
takes a lot of resources to do that
um
another source of frustration is uh
timely removal of providers from their
roles we I think I'm biased I think our
practice does a pretty good job of
informing insurers that someone is no
longer with us and
um we had one uh physician assistant who
left us in January of 2020 and about six
months ago that one insurer took them
off their provided directory and we've
had one who left us last January last
January who's still on provided
directories and why that's negative is
because patients call you I'd like to
see so and so and we then have to
explain to them that that person's no
longer with us and you know you get
questions and so on and it makes it
difficult and they don't typically blame
the insurance company for that
misinformation they blame the practice
um while this bill is very limited in
scope and makes one change we're hopeful
it's passage by this committee and its
enactment will assist by in causing
those insurers who do not meet these
standards who do a better job of working
with providers rather than working
against them and I understand part of
the problem is Staffing and that
insurers have these problems it's a very
complex process behind the scene with
insurance companies but it also creates
a big issue for practices and it creates
a big issue for our patients thank you
thank you for your information is there
seeing none thank you all right does
anyone else wish to testify on Senate
okay not seeing any of clues of public
hearing
um
does someone wish to make a motion on
Senate Bill 72
Madam chair I'll move OTP on House Bill
you should speak to your motion yes
um being personally familiar with this
process
and understanding the need for Effective
and efficient transfer of
credentials when a doctor moves from one
practice to the other
I think that this bill is um
takes care of that and it's unfortunate
that we have to do it this way
representative goalie
first I want to
probably
say I'm not sure why this bill is here
and representative hunt should be
thanking our committee for taking some
of his workload for the Senate bills
um
but in reality
um it's just I find it
appalling that
hearing
testimony that it could take up telling
their providers it could take up to 120
days before they can get into another
practice for through credentialing
it's
these individuals from what I'm hearing
have already been
under the provider care and are just
changing either an address or a
different
practice
and to have to take this long to
credential someone I find unacceptable
and like I said I I wish this was
a way to make it shorter than the 30
days because we are in a health care
crisis we need providers here in New
Hampshire and it shouldn't take this
shrimp
well I certainly second represent
goalie's remarks uh and it it's it seems
to me that this bill is going to
force
the process to
to
react a little bit more rapidly but what
I'm afraid is likely to happen is
they're going to acknowledge receipt
medel developed some kind of a
an excuse for why it can't be actually
implemented
I know within the 30 days but but as I
think we absolutely have to go forward
with this and the hope that it will you
know
provide the verbial kick in the
proverbial rear end
thank you representative Schmidt I'd
like to agree with that and say that I'm
glad the insurance department has a
uh
a policy of enforcing timeliness
requirements I'm just going to mention
that from the testimony it doesn't
appear to be that tightly enforced but
it needs to be done because
timeliness matters
all right no quit no other comments
in that case the motion is ought to pass
by representative Rhoda and the clerk
can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk votes
yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Michelle yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith
and the chair yes 18 yay zero nay
okay
18 to zero is there any objection to
consent
not seeing any we'll put this one on
and representative groder that's another
one you owe as soon as possible
and we have five minutes before the next
hearing
oh
foreign
okay welcome back I'm opening the
hearing on Senate bill 106.
and I don't see uh here
please you can talk to us first and then
hello everyone I am Senator Donovan
Fenton to represent uh district 10 which
is Cheshire county and part of
Hillsborough County I also want to
apologize I sprinted out of my office
and left my jacket there so I always
usually wear a jacket so that's on me
um I'm here to introduce Senate bill
106. this bill creates an emerging
professional certificate and the
requirements for HHS to issue these
certificates at a time when we are so
short staffed for teachers and
caregivers this would help them earn an
industry recognized certificate and this
would also help bring in high school
students into early educator positions
this would also make it easier to enter
the workforce and potentially earn a
higher wage I really want to emphasize
that an industry recognized credential
upon completing a high school CTE
program will not only help them earn a
higher wage but it'll help with
recruitment
um over 75 percent of CTE Learners
enroll in post-secondary education After
High School if kids are interested in a
career year we should foster that
interest and give them the tools they
need to succeed and that's all I have
thank you are there any questions for
Senator Fenton
thank you um
would you be
it says here that they need a high
school they need to have graduated from
high school right yes well CTE program
is in high school right so is would a
this is this is only available if I read
this correctly through the CTE programs
in very correct and I believe your GED
program's done after hours and things
thank you so
um to
um you know to take these jobs now
um what would these people have to do do
they have to get an occupational license
or what would they have to do currently
if this before this bill
um to get these jobs currently they have
to graduate a similar program or they
could do it right out of uh high school
without this credential however um this
helps recruitment in terms of
these children are actively in it so if
they're in the CTE program they you want
to catch them when they're in the
program because it's so because when
they leave they might not have an
interest in it if they earn this
industry recognized certificate
recruitment officers will actually go
after them
so what I'm getting at is um I mean
let's say they're in the CT program I'm
actually a big CTE fan yeah
um if they're in the CT program today
they finish this program
they get out they want to then go and
work what do they have to do around
credentialing now to be able to get a
job can they just go and get a job
without anything else HHS will probably
be able to answer that question better
than I can let's see thank you
okay anyone else but I also want to say
there's a lot of certificates for CTE
programs for a lot of in need jobs like
welding and things like that that aren't
a recognized credential
well I mean yeah I know there you can
come out we have one in Hudson where I'm
from at Auburn and uh you know students
come out of there and then go directly
and get a job as an LNA and have the
sort of the license for that as part of
the program
but I know that if they don't do it that
way they have to go out and then apply
for a license
I was wondering if there's a similar
thing here where this avoids them having
to apply directly for their first job
some kind of occupational license so I
think yeah HHS should be able to answer
all right thank you
they're questioned
all right thank you I think we need to
uh thank you uh Senator Khan has asked
to speak first
that's we have questions for HHS so
uh so I'm Brian Clark general counsel
for the
Bureau of Child Development and Head
Start collaboration
um
tell us the requirements if a high
school graduate who may or may not have
taken this class and does not have a
seat this certificate
wants a job in child care what other
credentials if any do they need okay
um so the other available credentials
are Early Childhood associate educator
uh early childhood and what are the
requirements for that uh so there are
additional training requirements above
this this is adding a lower rung to the
certification
um
ladder
yes representative Corona so I'm going
to help clarify
so the purpose of this
is to allow
those individuals who have passed this
CTE course
access to a career in early childhood
education without meeting the
requirements of additional
education or training that's correct so
this is kind of a base level entry into
this Market
um yes it's between being a being no
certification and being a
Early Childhood educator okay
follow up follow
if you were if you hadn't taken this
class let's say that you've got two
running programs you've got the CTE
program and you've got a high school
program right and the person in the CTA
program enters the child care world and
let's say this high school student also
wants to enter the child care world how
does that student enter that world do
they need to have participated in the
CTE program or is there something that
we can do for this high school student
who wants to enter the child at the same
level
um so this is
to add an additional report no no what
is it that the high school student who
didn't take the CTE classes what do they
need to do to enter at the same level as
the CTE student at any level let's start
with okay at any level
okay so they would be able to enter the
workforce
um however they wouldn't have this
additional certificate
um and would not be compensated yes
thank you okay I have a question
follow-up thank you what is the value of
the certificate then if it doesn't what
is the value of the certificate if the
high school student can enter the level
the same level as a CTE but the CTE
person has a certificate in the high
school doesn't
see where we're going you get two 18
year olds who have done the same thing
gone to different schools obviously
Okay so
that's where we're going that's where
we're going how what's the value of the
certificate and what does that give the
not only this the the participants or
the person who's entering the workforce
put the workforce itself okay it shows
to the employers prospective employers
that they have an interest in early
childhood education and that they've
and those skills are
listed in starting on page 25 on page
one
with the five five hours sorry
B one class that includes child
development and C A submission of a plan
for ongoing professional development
if one were not to one were to wish to
work in early childhood child care
but not be a teacher
um they would have to
apply
yes
I believe if I'm not mistaken chair that
we did I remember a bill
that this committee heard several years
ago
that expanded the availability of people
working in child care to grandparents
and people with life experience does
that sound familiar yes yes this is this
bill is I understand it is part of the
professionalizing of child care and
moving it more toward education rather
than just oversight and supervision
so this is intent attempting to increase
the education levels of the child care
we had a major policy disagreement on
that whether we should be pushing for
the
uh educational quality of the child care
providers or just the quantity of people
who would who could safely oversee
children and that has not been fully
resolved but this bill it appears to be
on the side of increasing the
perceived quality rather than quantity
would that be a correct assessment
I wouldn't disagree with it yeah okay
thank you
yes representative gold
just to try to thank you madam Sharon
thank you for taking my question just to
um make sure I understand clearly so the
um the certificate the goal is that the
certification standard might attract
people into the daycare worker field
that might otherwise not be interested
if there's no more money there's no uh
penalty against people who don't have
the certification but am I correct in
um
um so it is intended to incentivize
people because they can earn the
certificate which will signal to the
employer that they've completed
additional training uh so they would be
does that answer your question okay
Robson gerhardt thank you madam chair
why couldn't this be done by a private
um
I'm not aware of any the the
Bureau of child child development and
Head Start collaboration ra issues
certificates
um and credentials people for Early
Childhood so it's easier to assign it to
us because we've already
done this sort of process
and I don't believe there is a private
organization of child care providers
representative leckis thank you I'm just
I'm trying so trying to understand
um the benefit this gives above I mean
you can show
your high school transcript that you've
gone through a CT program and taking
these classes now
I don't see a significant difference am
employer if you're if you're approaching
an employer
um
so you're essentially asking if a person
has taken these classes but doesn't have
a certificate goes to a child care
employer and asks for a job
what's the difference
um essentially it is just shortcutting a
okay
I just want to clarify if I could so
what this bill does is it creates a sort
of if it's sort of like a fast track
right it creates a certificate to the
people certificate I'm sorry it's a new
type it's a new type of certification
that's why it's coming to us because
it's a licensing certification so this
certification would
um so they would have to apply and they
would meet the requirements and have to
apply and then the bureau would certify
them
question on that why isn't there at
least the criminal background check
that's required for every other person
in the child care field oh there there
still would be
um you have to complete
yes go on you have to complete you you
have to complete a background check to
but not for the certificate right
okay thank you that's
perfectly any other questions sir I've
done true
thank you madam chair I'm not familiar
with uh the CTE program at all
300 hours would have to be uh
concluded in the high school it's like
you're taking this during High School
and you've got 300 hours of classroom
in high school
you have to have 500 but at least 200 as
is portraying as for something else so
300 hours you have to take in high
school
it just seems that like how long would
I mean
an hour and a half a day uh
how many days would it take
to work up the 300 hours of plasma
I don't understand how the program would
work but how long would it take a
shouldn't these questions be directed to
former Senator Khan who is the expert on
this subject as opposed to this
gentleman who was the general counsel he
knows the eight representative Schmidt
If he if he doesn't know the answer he
can he can say so as other people have
said
if you please if you don't know the
answer then just say so two years
follow up and I thank you again thank
you madam chair
and the minimum of 200 hours of
observation lesson planning that would
because you'd have to be observing
lesson planning practice teaching under
the supervision
yes
thank you
okay thank you
Ferguson I'm Smith
this is my first experience so bear with
me
um I noticed that c the very last part
number four on the second page they have
to submit a plan for ongoing
professional development
how often does this license have to be
renewed
um do you have to submit a plan you're
uh there the license doesn't expire but
the plan to for ongoing professional
development is a requirement of it
okay but they'll
like teacher does not expire it's not a
license it's a credential it says you've
met these okay a certificate that says
you've met these qualifications okay and
therefore it doesn't expire but they do
have to do a professional development
um portfolio of some sort to keep it
going
okay now what if they didn't do that
would they lose their credential no well
they wouldn't get it in the first place
because
wait I guess it depends on how you
phrase the question
I chose
discovered after a week or two of work
that they really didn't like child care
and they decided not to bother their
credential would not be revoked that
they would not be eligible for a further
one okay
okay thank you
Vanessa all right thank you
thank you madam chair and it's a
pleasure to be back before you and uh
other legislative colleagues that I had
the pleasure of working with in my last
three terms but
I didn't seek re-election so I am Jay
Khan
a resident of Keene and uh
formerly state senator representing
I'm passing around some testimony but
hopefully I'll I'll try to avoid reading
the testimony and hopefully you will too
this bill is
providing an alternative Pathway to
credentialing High School completers of
an education career program who wish to
enter Early Childhood professional
careers
the emerging professional certificate
credential
it credentials high school students at
an age when their interest in early
childhood education is at its highest if
you think about college graduates as
they move on and they age
their interests go to Elementary and
high school students so it it really is
a sweet spot for trying to attract
people into the Early Childhood
professions
and when you think of a Career Technical
education and I appreciate
representative true's question uh
because let's let's establish a common
ground here students can complete a
program and graduate high school many
with a career Ready industry recognized
credential which is an IRC
in education we have lots of acronyms
and in Industry recognized credential
means something
it means that you have certain
competencies
that are standardized and that a a body
has recognized those qualifications and
issued an industry recognized credential
so that's the purpose behind this bill
and when you think of the other Career
Technical education programs that exist
uh somebody mentioned nursing exactly
right complete a nursing program and a
CTE you get a LNA a licensed nurse
assistant
an advanced manufacturing or engineering
technology program that you complete in
the CTE you get a SolidWorks credential
for design
uh if it's welding or Machining there
are credentials for that
if it's traveling tourism and culinary
arts there is clear uh entry uh
validation is a sous chef
um if it's information Technologies it's
issued by Microsoft or Cisco who offer
industry recognized entry-level
credentials for information technology
but for a CTE student who's interested
in filling a position in Early Child
Care there is no industry recognized
credential and so this bill aims to fill
that void establishing that industry
recognized credential will give the high
school CTE student
completer an opportunity to earn that
credential and improve their job
earnings so that's how this works
for an early child care worker the
salary difference between job entry and
that first credential is two dollars an
hour
but if your job entry level salary is
only fourteen dollars an hour
two dollars an hour is a fourteen
percent increase
so it is a meaningful step
for somebody who is a high school
student
needing to graduate from high school
earning a credential and earning
fourteen percent more when they enter
the field that is the incentive here to
attract and retain Early Childhood
Workforce
and uh
these high school graduates deserve to
earn more than an unskilled job entry
candidate
who will earn fourteen dollars an hour
the community college system in New
Hampshire gives
CTE program completers college credit
and that's called their running Start
program
and for instance in the attached table
which comes from the Cheshire Career
Center
um
a student completing this program
gets six hours of community college
credit
if you're familiar with the other
credentialing for early child care
workers
it is both credits and hours of
experience that allow you to progress
towards a Lead Teacher credential that's
that's the real gold uh standard here
for Early Childhood classroom leaders
uh but
we're talking about folks that are going
to be assisting those classroom leaders
uh
so
um
and I can reference my experience uh as
a board member for Southwestern
Community Services which is one of five
community action programs in the state
of New Hampshire
they are charged with administering the
Head Start programs which are the
largest child care providers in the
state
and
uh
Southwestern Community Services covers
both Cheshire and Sullivan counties and
they're contracted with the U.S
Department of Health and Human Services
to serve 170 kids between three and five
years of age
but because of the Staffing shortage
that we're experiencing in early
childhood
uh
there are classrooms that are that have
been empty this entire Academic Year
in Claremont we have students
that are there are 17 children on a wait
list because that Head Start classroom
cannot be staffed
in Newport there are there's a classroom
and a waiting list of 10 students
because that classroom cannot be staffed
and the real downside to this if this
perpetuates itself is that the U.S
Department of Education can take that
170 students and because they're only
120 being served currently because of
Staffing shortages
they'll reduce future contracts down to
120 students I can't speak for the other
four cap agencies
but losing a third of the enrollment in
each of these programs would be
devastating both to the funding formula
it makes these successful and to the
workforce in the state that's dependent
on child care services
from the largest Child Care providing
program in the nation and in the state
so this chronic under enrollment can
result in the head start funding
decrease it will lock in lower student
enrollment in the future and the other
downsides are continuing understaffing
and younger workers being discouraged
from entering the workforce because they
can't get child care
um so this bill is just a common sense
way to break a vicious cycle we can
serve both our children and our families
better by expanding Early Child Care
Workforce through a well-defined high
school education and experience pathway
and Senate Bill 106 begins a scaffolding
pathway for a high school student to
enter the Early Child Care professions
with that industry recognized credential
that begins to lead them to higher
credentials through an associate degree
program at New Hampshire community
colleges or baccalaureate degree program
at New Hampshire colleges and
universities
this is why I'm present today to ask the
Eda committee to please
give an ought to pass to this bill so
that we can begin to address these vital
Workforce needs in our state
thank you madam chair
are there questions
Samantha representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair
so
Representatives representative growth is
earlier question to the previous witness
with regard to a previous bill that we
had and you were probably in the
in the Senate at the time that Bill
maybe it had something to do with you as
a matter of fact but there were the
committee at that time looked at this
need which was crying on the part of
Health Care Child Care Providers they
Target in Walmart and so forth who were
paying them somewhat more money with no
credentials whatsoever
start right off the bat and the and the
child care workers were having to get
continuing education credits to increase
their their in their qualification
certification so it is the situation now
worse than it was then a couple years
ago
I'd say it's unchanged and we know that
Target and Walmart are are increasing
their their base wage I'm talk I'm
talking primarily about how much the
need for child care workers is vis-a-vis
what it was a couple of years ago I'd
say I think it's worse worse in your
opinion follow up
thank you so
um what is the experience of child of
child care providers with people of this
age as employees and in general if you
can categorize
so and and actually excuse me just let
me yeah
flesh out my question a little bit
because you said they the the people you
know people in this age group have the
greatest affinity for work in child care
that they'll ever have okay as a general
categorization so can you put those
together in an answer
thanks for the question
um the
uh first off let me say Deb Nelson uh
who leads this credentialing effort for
Health and Human Services has been a
partner on this legislation and I
appreciate Mr Clark being available
today to answer your questions uh on the
there is an emerging professional
certificate already offered by the
department
and a
child care worker
who enters
any age doesn't matter has to work 750
hours in order to earn that emerging
professional
certificate
that's impossible for a high school
student I mean think about it this 500
but to not give Equal Credit to students
who've had three courses in early
childhood to a person who's had no
courses in early childhood and nearly
750 hours of of classroom assistance
it's just not comparable
uh and and it's unachievable and so
these students are walking out and and
and get no credit
for this for their classroom experience
that's that's the downside
excuse me
did I hear you say this is an existing
credential and all you're doing is
changing the requirements for students
who complete the CTE
it's a it's a dual track it's another
track I I understand that but there is
an emerging professional credential
right now believe that the department
I believe that's true
okay and so this says that instead of
taking X hours of supervised experience
and so many cat courses at the community
college you can take the CTE
to be eligible for that credential
um there is no course requirement for
the 750 hour
emerging professional thank you so it's
not available through a community
college Senator Schmidt but I I thought
that was an important point to no I
appreciate your intervention Madam chair
because this is all part of a complex
that we're trying to understand the
benefits uh and downsides of there are
and so Alternatives and so forth because
you want our support for this bill we
know from those of us who were here a
couple years ago and had that bill
before us a crying need
in the Healthcare in the child care
industry for staff
they have ratio requirements do they not
if they don't have the people they can't
have the kids
right so it's out there thank you
um
before we go any further Mr Clark could
you get your department or someone in
them to give us a quick table of the
various
Child Care licenses and the requirements
for them as they exist right now I was
just glancing at the statute and it
doesn't appear to be obvious so if you
could have somebody interpret it for us
to say you could have this these are the
levels of licensure and these are the
requirements for them we would very much
appreciate that while we were
considering this bill
representative would like us and then
Gerhart thank you
um so
am I correct in in understanding the 750
hour certificate you mentioned that some
150 hours basically of work experience
in a classroom as opposed to attending a
class is that
correct that's correct okay thank you
the other question I had well but but
there is there is a
practice teaching component to these I
understand High School for the existing
one you mentioned
um and on this one has there been a
discussion with the industry as to
whether they'll actually recognize this
thing
if if we put it in place
yes
yes thank you
gerhardt
thank you madam chair
just following up on representative
Smith's question about
the on the last page see the submission
of a plan for ongoing professional
development
so you do that when you first get into
the program or you say okay I'm gonna be
here in five years nobody checks on that
and it's never updated correct so this
is just a one and done you just make up
a dream list and that's done correct
uh
I
believe that that gets you the
certificate it's it is a certificate
it's not a it's not a license so it's uh
yes thank you thank you representative
Simon
thank you madam chair um as I've been
listening to testimony it seems to me
and correct me if I'm wrong the purpose
of this is twofold one is to attract
students to go into early childhood
education education and the second would
be
um that it creates a financial incentive
for them to do so
um
my question is
you said that typically if a student
goes on to like their bachelor's degree
or whatever they tend to go more towards
elementary school education or secondary
education as opposed to this
um
what what is the incentive for the
student or the employee in this case to
go with early childhood education over
elementary school or secondary education
like why would why would we be trying to
incentivize them to do this as opposed
to doing the other two
as opposed to moving on to moving on to
Elementary education and secondary level
education well what benefit is the
student getting out of making the choice
to go directly into this because if they
don't they'll lose interest going into
this as opposed to pursuing those other
career paths
because
uh
they qualify
and some students I mean work is a
necessity for some of our high school
completers
and this gives them that entry level
credential
and recognizes the education and
experience that they've already
accomplished through their school
program
many schools have school-based child
care programs and so whether they have
Partnerships outside of the school that
the these hours are going to be
accomplished or they have uh Day Care
within the school Child Care within the
school
they're going to get both the classroom
and the and and and and they qualify for
it so this is that kind of scaffolding
and we see it in so many education
programs that students
can enter with this qualification earn a
few dollars more per hour continue on
because that's what the plan is all
about is to give you know that you've
thought about how what are my next steps
if I want to be successful in this field
uh and there are steps like an assistant
teacher and then a Lead Teacher and then
then you can operate your own school and
become an employer I mean these are the
kind of wonderful kinds of things that
could happen but many students just just
need that entry level wage and then they
can continue on through the community
college program and Achieve that
assistant teacher credential I believe
they've got it to complete now then nine
hours of which they've got six hours of
credit so it's really just one more
Community College program after they
complete this uh and and then uh
the the number of hours that are
necessary to qualify for that that's a
scaffolding stepping stone
a follow-up well
my other question is you had mentioned
uh a two hour two dollar an hour
increase for the first credential that
they get on the rung is that
um
are you getting that from a credential
that already exists and if so what
credential would that be it is the uh
emerging license certificate that
and is that are you saying that two
dollars is industry wider is that only
for state-run programs I I can only
speak to the Head Start programs thank
you
all right thank you very much senator
is there anyone else who wishes to
106. sorry
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee hadn't intended to speak but
but I will Peggy Gilmore uh from pretty
strategies representing the greater
Nashville Chamber of Commerce and I just
wanted to relay that last evening we had
a legislative crossover reception which
gathered Business Leaders in our
community and legislate legislators from
the district and the topics were how do
we Foster our Workforce and our economic
development in particularly this it was
in the greater Nashville area and there
were two themes that came out
consistently over and over again and
that was the need for housing affordable
housing and child care it was Child Care
Child Care Child Care
and the this bill came up specifically
uh not as any kind of Panacea but is one
more piece of the puzzle that we could
put together to make this uh really a
crisis
to allow people back into the workforce
entering the workforce and to give uh
Senator Khan said uh the a ladder a
scaffolding for our young people to get
into this field with interest uh and
enthusiasm at their their time of
finishing up high school so bringing
them in and hopefully being one more
piece to help relieve the pressure on
this great it's really a crisis for our
families and for our businesses that are
looking to hire
and that's all thank you very much for
Testimony because there are
representative gold
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question as I'm listening to
all the testimony it's striking me and
I'm wondering if you would um agree that
um we're sort of talking about for years
babysitting was kind of an a note just a
nothing thing maybe sort of compared
with mothering
which is not enough and we all know that
but I'm just talking about historically
our culture hasn't valued those things
as much as being a teacher and an
educator and I'm wondering if this in
some ways is a way to help our young
people see a greater value in caring for
young children as much as in educating
in a more traditional educational system
do you think that might be a part of
what makes this so popular
um thank you for that question I think
anything that that elevates uh
the the idea that that investing in our
youngest
uh in any way is I mean it is a
Continuum if we get our middle youngest
our high schools to to Value investing
in our littlers it can only be uh
an upswing for for all of us
okay thank you other questions
all right thank you very much for your
testimony does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill 106.
all right seeing none I'm going to close
the public hearing and I I will send
this to the licensing committee to take
a look at what's currently there because
this is the first
time this session we've had to deal with
okay
down so we're done for the day
thank you all we I hope anyone who has a
committee report please turn it in as
soon as possible subcommittee chairs
please schedule your work
Adam Chan yes I may briefly
I I saw a scheduling come out today and
we scheduled for the 26th Senate bill
105. yeah
and looking at that that shouldn't be
vacated to Health and Human Services
when I look at the subject matter it
came out of a no study committee from
Senate Bill 454 which is a second
committee when it came from the Senate
went to Health and Human Services for
that study committing the approval
and I think once again we've already
heard two bills in this committee that
should have gone to Commerce
and I'm not sure who's delving out the
bills this time around but they're
looking at what committee
the Senate bills go to instead of
looking at the RSA and the content the
reason that I've I've talked to a couple
of people about this bill that's the
Senate bill 105. the reason that it
belongs with Edna is that it is about
the relationship between HHS and the
Secretary of State who has the vital
records it's not just within HHS it's
the Secretary of State as well and
that's what we're trying to deal with
and I did notice that there's a whole
lot of bills that should have gone to
two committees that aren't assigned to
two committees and that's one of them
they should have gone to HHS and then to
us
okay because
obviously the study committee that this
bill came out of went through Health and
Human Services so they have the
expertise so I'm hoping someone's going
to be here to explain why this came out
of that study Community because probably
none of us were on it representative
Lucas was
so hopefully we can and I I should I
should mention that in the Senate it
sailed through Edna and then it went to
finance for some reason and they made a
major amendment that totally changed the
bill so
committees not for us no you're off the
hook every like literally everybody else
but not you
[Laughter]
foreign